>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THE UNITED STATES AS EVERY
FOURTH-GRADER LEARNS AS A
MERITOCRACY.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
IT MEANS THAT THE LEADERS ARE
NOT INHERITED THEIR POSITION,
OUR LEADERS ARE SELECTED ON THE
BASIS OF MERIT.
AND THEN UP THEY GO FROM THERE.
ONLY THE SMARTEST KIDS WE ARE
TOLD TO GET INTO YALE.
LIKE INCANDESCENT MINES LIKE
CORY BOOKER AND CHRIS CUOMO.
NERDS THEY CALL THEMSELVES WITH
FALSE MODESTY.
THE ORDINARY AMONG US MEANWHILE
GO TO RUTGERS.
IN THIS COUNTRY THE HARD TRUTH
IS, AND GET USED TO IT, PAL.
IS THE MOST IMPRESSIVE,
NATURALLY RISE TO THE TOP,
THAT'S WHAT THEY TELL US.
DO YOU STILL BELIEVE THAT OR,
ARE WE AND STARTING TO SUSPECT
THAT THE WHOLE MERITOCRACY
SPEECH MIGHT BE AN ELABORATE
JUSTIFICATION FOR KEEPING
MEDIOCRE PEOPLE IN CHARGE?
BEFORE YOU MAKE UP YOUR MIND ON
THE QUESTION, CONSIDER RUSSIA.
IT'S NOT THE NATION OF RUSSIA
THAT HASN'T CHANGED IN A WHILE,
RUSSIA IS STILL A COLD AND VODKA
SOAKED AND ONLY MARGINALLY
RELEVANT PLACE.
AND TO THEM, VERSUS THE MOST
SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD.
AND, THAT HE STOPPED A U.S.
SENATOR IN HIS TRACKS AND ALL
BUT ACCUSED HIM OF SPYING FOR
RUSSIA.
WATCH THIS EXCHANGE.
>> IN DECEMBER 2018 A UKRAINIAN
COURT RULED THAT UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS HAD VIOLATED UKRAINIAN
LAW BY MEDDLING IN OUR ELECTION.
THAT WAS REPORTED IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES"
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
>> ACCORDING TO
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO, U.S. SENATORS WERE
BRIEFED THAT ACTUALLY THIS
ENTIRE EFFORT TO FRAME THE
UKRAINE FOR THE RUSSIAN MEDDLING
OF 2016, OF WHICH YOU JUST MADE
THIS CASE THAT THEY'VE DONE IT.
ACTUALLY, THIS IS AN EFFORT OF
PROPAGANDA AND THIS IS A RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE PROPAGANDA CAMPAIG
CAMPAIGN.
AND THAT HELPS PEOPLE LIKE YOU
TO SAY THINGS ABOUT UKRAINE.
ARE YOU AT ALL CONCERNED THAT
YOU ARE DOING RUSSIA
INTELLIGENCE WORK HERE?
THE ONE WHILE G CHUCK, NOW THAT
YOU PUT IT THAT WAY.
THAT'S PRETTY FUNNY.
BUT WHAT'S FUNNIER OR WEIRDER
IS, WE NOW KNOW IT'S NOT REALLY
A STORY.
IT NEVER HAPPENED, THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION.
RUSSIA DIDN'T PACK OUR
DEMOCRACY.
THE WHOLE THING, AND THAT'S
UNEXPECTED DEFEAT IN THE LAST
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
AND THAT'S THE RUSSIA CONSPIRACY
THEORY.
THAT AND THAT CONSPIRACY THEORY
HAS DIED AND WAS KILLED IN FACT
BY ROBERT MUELLER.
AND THAT'S THE STEERING
INFORMATION OF THE PUBLIC AND
INFORMATIONAL.
PEOPLE LIKE THAT COULD BE
CONTRITE AND MAYBE EVEN HUMBLED
AFTER THE MUELLER REPORT CAME
OUT AND PROVED TO YEARS OF
HYPERVENTILATION WRONG.
BUT NO.
THEY ARE MORE OBSESSED WITH
RUSSIA THAN THEY HAVE EVER BEEN.
CHUCK TODD WENT FULL JOE
McCARTHY YESTERDAY.
>> THE FACT THAT RUSSIA WAS SO
AGGRESSIVE DID NOT EXCLUDE THE
FACT THAT PRESIDENT POROSCHENKO
ACTIVELY WORKED FOR
SECRETARY CLINTON.
NOW IF I'M WRONG -- MY GOODNESS.
SENATOR KENNEDY, YOU NOW HAVE
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UKRAINE
SAYING HE ACTIVELY WORKED FOR
THE DEMOCRATIC SENATOR.
YOU REALIZE THE ONLY OTHER
PERSON SETTLING THIS ARGUMENT
OUTSIDE OF THE UNITED STATES IS
THIS MAN, VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> Tucker: VLADIMIR PUTIN.
ARE YOU NOW OR HAVE YOU EVER
BEEN UPON A VLADIMIR PUTIN?
YOU WOULD THINK -- THEY WOULD
SAY THINGS LIKE THAT OUT LOUD
BUT OF COURSE THEY NEVER DO.
NOT ONLY ARE THESE PEOPLE UNWISE
AND HYSTERICAL, THEY ARE ALSO
KIND OF DUMB.
AND BECAUSE SHIFTING MENTAL
GEARS IS HARD FOR DUMB PEOPLE,
PEOPLE ARE STILL PRETENDING THAT
RUSSIA COLLUSION IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT STORY THERE IS.
IT'S LIKE ROBERT MUELLER NEVER
DELIVERED HIS REPORT.
>> DONALD TRUMP TAKES -- HE'S
ACTING AS A RUSSIAN ASSET.
HE'S AMPLIFYING TALKING POINTS
PUT TOGETHER BY THE KREMLIN.
>> I CAN'T COME UP WITH A
POSSIBLE EXPLANATION FOR ALL OF
THESE ELECTED OFFICIALS SEEM TO
JUST WANT TO TURN OUR GOVERNMENT
OVER TO VLADIMIR PUTIN.
>> THIS TIME THE ENEMY IS RUSSIA
WHICH SEEMS TO HAVE CONSUMED ONE
OF AMERICA'S GREAT POLITICAL
PARTIES.
>> THE CONSTITUTION IS A PIECE
OF PAPER THAT THEY WOULD RATHER
RIP UP OR CUT INTO SEGMENTS
RATHER THAN DEFEND THIS COUNTRY
AT ALL COSTS.
AND, THEY JOINED THE BAD GUYS IN
THE WORLD, AND THE REPUBLICANS
AT-LARGE SEEM TO BE OKAY WITH I
IT.
>> THAT WAS LED BY A KREMLIN
ASSET.
THE WORDS OF BEEN EX-COMMUNIST
DICTATOR, RATHER THAN ANY PERSON
IN AMERICA.
WE ARE IN DANGER.
THIS IS REALLY IRRESPONSIBLE.
KEEP IN MIND THAT EVERYTHING WE
JUST PLAY DO AIRED IN THE PAST
TWO WEEKS.
IF YOU EXCLUDED DEBUNKED
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, COULD ANY
OF THESE PEOPLE ACTUALLY TELL
YOU WHY VLADIMIR PUTIN IS SO BA
BAD?
WHY IS HE SO BAD?
HE'S BAD.
TODD SAYS, SPEAK SLOWLY SO I CAN
UNDERSTAND.
WHAT MAKES VLADIMIR PUTIN WORSE
THAN A WHOLE LONG LIST OF
AMERICAN ALLIES?
LET'S TRY THE KING OF
SAUDI ARABIA FOR EXAMPLE WERE
THE PEOPLE WHO RUN THE EMIRATES.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE ON THAT
PAYROLL.
WHY IS HE WORSE THAN THEM?
THEY COULDN'T ANSWER THAT.
FOR CHUCK TODD AND THE REST OF
THE DUMMIES, VLADIMIR PUTIN IS
ISN'T A REAL PERSON WITH COUNTRY
AND POLICE COMIC HE'S A LIVING
METAPHOR.
AND LET'S PUT HIS PICTURE ON THE
SCREEN.
CAN WE GET HIS PICTURE ON THE
SCREEN?
PLEASE.
THE IRONY OF COURSE IS THAT
PRUDENT FOR ALL HIS FAULTS DOES
NOT HATE AMERICA IS MUCH AS MANY
OF THESE PEOPLE DO.
THEY REALLY DISLIKE OUR COUNTRY.
AND THEY CALL OTHER PEOPLE
TRADERS?
BECAUSE THEY ARE MOUTHING THE
TALKING POINTS OF PRUDENT.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO DON'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT RUSSIA, WHO DON'T
SPEAK RUSSIAN.
WHO COULDN'T IDENTIFY THREE IN
RUSSIA.
THE REST OF THE WORLD IS NOT
QUITE THAT DUMB, AS DUMB AS THAT
MAY BE, IT'S NOT QUITE THAT
DUMB.
THE FRENCH PRESIDENT, HE HAS
CALLED NATO "BRAIN-DEAD" BECAUSE
NATO EXIST TO PROVIDE COMMON
DEFENSE AND YET IT HAS WITH THE
FALL OF THE SOVIET UNION IN
1991, NUCLEAR ENERGY
1991, NUCLEAR ENTRGY
1991, NUCLEAR ENTITY.
IN THE UNITED STATES, HE HAS
SAID TO HAVE CLOSER
RELATIONSHIPS WITH RUSSIA, NOT
MORE HOSTILE ONES.
SO DOES THAT MAKE HIM A STOOGE
OF PRUDENT?
IS HE A PUPPET OF MOSCOW?
OR COULD HE JUST BE RATIONAL
LEADER, THE KIND THAT WE DON'T
HAVE LOOKING OUT FOR HIS
COUNTRY'S INTEREST.
RUSSIA IS NOT AMERICA'S MAIN --
AND THE UNITED STATES OUGHT TO
BE IN A RELATIONSHIP WITH RUSSIA
ALIGNED AGAINST CHINA.
CHINA IS CURRENTLY MURDERING
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS
EVERY YEAR WITH FENTANYL.
IT'S PUSHING OUR LIFE EXPECTANCY
DOWN.
THAT'S HOW PROFOUND A THREAT
THIS IS.
MANY OF OUR POLITICIANS RUN
INTERFERENCE.
IN CALIFORNIA, POLITICIANS
BOYCOTT, HE DENIES THAT CHINA IS
A DICTATORSHIP AT ALL.
WATCH THIS.
>> CHINA IS DOING A LOT.
>> THEY ARE NOW MOVING GLANCE
AWAY FROM THE CITY'S, AND THE
COMMUNIST PARTY WANTS TO STAY IN
POWER AND CHINA AND THEY LISTEN
TO THE PUBLIC.
PUBLIC SAYS I CAN'T BRING
BREATHE THE AIR.
HE HAS TO SATISFY HIS
CONSTITUENTS OR HE'S NOT GOING
TO SURVIVE.
>> HE'S NOT A DICTATOR?
>> HE HAS A CONSTITUENCY TO
ANSWER TO.
>> Tucker: SPEAKING OF STOOGES
STOOGES, THE DICTATOR IS NOT A
DICTATOR.
THAT IS PRIMA FACIE
DISQUALIFYING AND YET NO ONE HAS
EVEN NOTICED.
BLOOMBERG'S COMMENTS HAVE GOTTEN
NOT 1% OF ANYTHING RUSSIA
RELATED.
THOUGH THAT TAPE MAKES YOU